[Music]
from the producer hell-bent on taking
all the fun out of your childhood toys
comes the reboot that somehow gets the
spirit of the four heroes right but
absolutely nothing else we will drain
every last ounce of their blood
even if it kills them Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles
the turtles are back and they're scary
ish
meet these four roided-out the nightmare
versions of Schrag with some of the most
needlessly complicated back stories of
all time where they were born in the lab
of April O'Neill's father making them
April's childhood pets who she tries to
save in a fire then immediately dumps
them down a sewer for some reason where
they're raised by a mutant rat who
quickly learned how to become a ninja
from reading a book that someone flushed
down the toilet
huh what's wrong with you is falling
down the sewer like they did in the
cartoon you weren't dying to see fan
favorites like Krang Casey Jones bebop
and Rocksteady instead get ready for
April O'Neil the movie a film all about
her quest to be taken seriously as a
journalist oh now I get it you want to
be a serious journalist while being
sexually objectified by her co-workers
and the director of the movie that's
good and even her own childhood bed so
hot I can get my shout time we can still
have dope
I have a real nice song this all cued up
it's special girl that's my girl yeah
you know Eternals genitals are half the
length of their bodies so good luck with
that Mikey William Fichtner is the
shredder or at least he was supposed to
be until the nerd rage of a thousand
fanboys has changed the studio's mind
and now it's this random Japanese guy
who we never really see or get to know
in a bunch of painfully obvious reshoots
together they'll hatch an evil plan to
poison New York City then sell them a
mutagen they created that can cure all
disease we developed a mutagen capable
of stimulating self-repair a cellular
level instead of just selling the Cure
on the open market that's gotta be worth
something right suit up for project that
was only produced by Michael Bay but
still has everything you'd expect from a
movie he directed like things going babe
Megan Fox fart jokes a big old truck
Shia LaBeouf a gratuitous slo-mo
unnecessary camera spins and tons of
product placement Orange Crush behind
the fridge all the pizza places in New
York City to choose from and they go at
Pizza Hut you're in New York you got
Ray's Ray's original famous Ray's famous
original Ray's Ray's famous world
original and you got a pizza daddy here
so ride along for a story you've totally
seen before Hamish you are part of super
data cowabunga heroes in the half-shell
for this below-average reboot that's all
would ruin the franchise hey pretty cool
where'd you come from kid why are you
being so mean Michelangelo is funny but
the plot was terrible and they
completely ruined the characters kids
movie right it's not like trolls are
better than your day they were douche eh
can we at least agree the new one needs
a mutant warthog and a badass rhino
are you listening Michael Bay story
leads does machines cool the crude a
party dude mr. Miyagi whoopee cushion
foxnews fruit ninja you've made a huge
mistake
and the Iron Throne corporate reboot
cash grab Turtles not for nothing but we
totally call this two years ago oh man
the Ninja Turtles are be sure to
subscribe for more honest trailers I
love ham this ham stays where it is
purple monkey dishwasher hingle
mccringleberry put the pieces into the
slot make the right connection but the
quick erasing the clock pow
pop goes perfection now this is a story
all about how my life got flipped turned
upside down not just mumbo jumbo but
extra jumbo mumbo jumbo